Haaaaaaa
Merci tout le monde
Oh oh oh oh
[musique]
maintenant
[applaudissements]
[musique]
Environ 5 jours par semaine pour moi aussi
J'ai travaillé environ 6 jours
je l'ai complètement perdu
Hmm
Le salaire horaire des deux hommes est négatif pour la première fois à l'âge
de
jusqu'ici
Je suis dans cette industrie depuis 17 ans.
C'est ma première fois
[musique]
Après tout, le travail de chat de la geisha a été grandement affecté, il n'y a donc pas de ventes ou quelque chose comme ça.
Mais je me demande si je peux faire quelque chose de positif.
Créer des opportunités pour les personnes qui n'ont jamais rencontré de geisha à l'école de rencontrer une geisha.
Je ne peux rien faire pour que les gens connaissent la geisha de Hakone.
C'est pourquoi j'ai lancé une beuverie en ligne
S'il vous plaît allez à
Yano
C'est le moment
ne le dis pas à tout le monde
[musique]
ouvrir dans
perle
merci
Parce que ma ville natale est Odawara pour le stockage
Je veux vraiment soutenir Hepro le jour passé, donc tout le monde.
La forme de Suzuyama pos Parce que c'est magnifique, je pensais que je ferais n'importe quoi et j'ai pu le faire correctement
Alors
Bien
moi
Oh oh oh
[musique]
Ouais ok
Ouais
[musique]
quoi
Ouais
Je suis
un compagnon
[musique]